oh hi there you may be wondering what it  is about that deep sexy boys avoid  luscious pink must acid makes your  downstairs quiver and fear the sexiness  presented before you  well that would be all thanks to central  PL inside this bottle is a specially  designed formula to make you  irresistible to everyone you meet and I  mean  just take a look at these Oh so sexually  satisfied customers  F now this is some good stuff  holy [ __ ] this is great oh whoa whoa  whoa listen to my voice lalalala i'm  markiplier huh this is crazy  I just came well I don't like that you  may be wondering how to be conjure up  this oh so succulent spray well it was  really simple  all we did was gathered a seventh  building of a dragon the [ __ ] of an  armored car freshly popped Lublin the  laughs of a newborn fawn and it's blood  and of course our secret ingredient so  what do you say feeling sexy today by  our spray fax us in order today and you  will be living the simple in Korean life  no time